in the bitter cold waiting in a queue
can feel longer than it already is
theirs is a story of people fleeing a
war they didn't expect mothers taking
their children across the border
families being torn apart as men between
the age of 18 to 60 are not allowed to
leave Ukraine under martial law
Marina a Diversey who's traveling alone
with her 12 year old son stayed in Kiev
for as long as she could
[Music]
say we stayed because we thought the war
would end at any moment it was
relatively quiet in our way we heard the
bombing but we didn't think it would get
to us until the very last moment we
realized we had to escape when we heard
missiles flying over our head
despite the warnings few believed that
war would break out until it actually
happened
they tell about how they were caught off
guard not expecting to become refugees
and in the midst a group of Indian
students who arrived in harkiv only
three weeks ago to start medical school
it was around 16 days we were like we
thought that there will be no war they
were they were just argue and all but
suddenly this happened and we were we
all went to the bunker and we had a you
know we had a really hard time there
were no facilities through which we uh
we could escape from there so we decided
to go by foot we traveled I guess 30
kilometers by foot and finally reached
pole Tower and then we managed to move
from there with a bus
a little further down the line Janus has
been is trying to cheer her up these are
the last moments they will be together
as a family until who knows when
she's afraid for me he says but I think
she will be bored without me she will
have nobody to nag
they have traveled for three days from
zaporija in the East where the Russian
army is advancing
uh yeah
I woke up at 5am because I heard a huge
loud bang I thought something fell down
from the Shelf in the room next door but
the airport was being bombed
ruslana made the same Journey leaving
behind her husband's sister nieces and
nephew she's begging them to move fast
before they get caught up in the
fighting she's upset that her life has
been upended it was a good simple one
and she had plans for the future and she
rejects Russia's President Vladimir
Putin's claims that civilians are not
being targeted
ah
yeah
this is not true it's full scale we're
being annihilated people are dying
children elderly everybody we had to run
by foot as soon as there was an
opportunity it's not true they're
killing us
um
many of the people here are Russian
speakers those putting claim this war is
aiming to protect they became victims of
a conflict that started in their name Al
Jazeera along the Ukraine Romania border